Paulino that's why we talk about cyber
we'll talk about
cyberattacks we talk about security what
do you see as the main threats coming up
well I think I think they're both
threats and they're different and I
think it's very confusing for the public
you know when they're when they're
spoken about in the same breath I mean
the the the terrorist threat clearly is
the ability of governments technical and
legal to intercept communications such
that they can attract people who are out
to do us harm
that's one set of issues and a lot of
the communications in the Internet age
and are carried on American systems so
there's a jurisdictional issue that we
have to try and deal with which means we
have to get agreement between
governments there's also an encryption
issue cyber cyber security is much more
to do with the security of data on your
systems and the security of those
systems themselves and that is companies
its governments it's it's you and me
it's your my finances which need to be
protected against thieves and against
people who actually want to disrupt the
system and bring it down and for
instance cause the lights to go out you
know because an energy company is
attacked so I think what the
government's are saying to each other
there is let us do some gaming let us
actually see how resilient our systems
are against this kind of attack and we
can help each other the problem is is
the polynomial so shouldn't talk about
the two together but they are linked on
the grounds that in yeah in terms of if
you're giving security services access
security also conflated on that which is
it deliberately so I think you want I
mean one thing that we've learned from
the way for example that so-called
Islamic state have been using the
Internet is I suppose something that the
intelligence agencies have known for a
very long time which is that the
terrorists and the serious and organized
criminals are keen users of technology
they're always looking for ways to
innovate they're very very smart and as
a result it's incredibly difficult for
the intelligence age
is to always stay on top of them now the
the problem that I see here is that
particularly since the Edward Snowden
revelations there has been a huge growth
in often actually civil liberties
activists who are trying to create sort
of open-source
easy-to-use encryption software for very
good reasons
for reasons of sort of protecting
journalistic sources for human rights
activists but we also know that the
terrorists and the organized criminals
will be among the early adopters too and
I think that is what David Cameron was
really talking about that we don't want
there to be dark spaces where the
intelligence agencies cannot go because
the technology is too strong I agree
with that the problem is how do you
ensure that the intelligence agencies
can get everywhere without undermining
confidence in all the other reasons we
use encryption without undermining
confidence in the Internet as a whole
and that I think that's the unanswered
that's where the legal safeguards come
in and that's that's where legislation
has to be right only thing is what
you're hearing about what David Cameron
had to say when it came to you know
encryption some people called it he's
technically literate he doesn't know
what he's talking about this is a little
bit about file horribly well you're
probably talking to the wrong person
because I some of this technology's way
beyond me as well
but I think as a matter of principle I
think I'd agree exactly what the London
sort of being said that this is you know
more and more of us spend more and more
of our time and effort and activity in
cyberspace and it does need policing but
where are the limits and so this is less
a question about cyber it's more a
question about civil about politics
about policy and I think there we get
obsessed by the technical Meister's of
it but these policy questions are
absolutely key and the real public needs
to get engaged with this this is not an
issue just for the cyber technicians
it's an actual issue for people all
about as we're hearing tonight about
their civil liberties and how they how
we draw that balance because at the
moment our whole reaction to cyber is is
unbalanced and what we're seeing now is
the government trying to do what I think
is a sensible thing to do which is
actually allow people to police
cyberspace but the problem is the public
are alarmed by this and we just need to
educate the public and there needs to be
a very the sort of clear exposition you
just heard from the Baroness here about
the nature of cyberspace is more
education is
the sort of education that public needs
because in the end that's gonna need it
with the public to decide what they're
going to tolerate okay Jimmy there
should be there shouldn't be dark
corners of the internet I think there
should be dark corners of the internet
actually and I think it's even if it
means child abuse or terrorism but
they're I think they're actually quite a
small part I think if you have a free
society where there's free speech it's
actually very important that there are
places where people who actually don't
have anything to hide can nonetheless be
private you know you have an entitlement
to to to privacy and I think it's
important that we facilitate that it is
if you like a penalty we pay for the
price of free speech and for freedom
that we also have within our midst
people who want to do is harm who want
to say horrible things you want to cause
and death and mayhem but I think the
principle of freedom is really too
important to think about giving away the
other question arising from the concept
of PCs who does the policing because
it's not a national issue
it's a supranational issue and I think
it one of the concerns is this the US
can't police it is the UK good to police
it who's going to place it the Chinese
you know the internet social media
providers well they're wrong I'm just
very sorry that they shouldn't be arms
of the state which is effectively what
is being talked about here you know they
should be the idea is that they should
be keeping an eye I said well when lirik
these killers were apparently still
talking on Facebook there was a lot of
grief with Facebook about this and no
Facebook doesn't have a duty to hand
over to the state somebody they think
might be doing something dodgy it's it's
pre-emptive know what I'll soon be well
if we are going to have a free-for-all
if we're going to allow which we do
people to generate these enormous
amounts of big data then actually that's
over free for all for the security
services as possible and actually lift
some of the restrictions off that well
I'm not sure I'm in that camp I mean I
actually do think they have got to have
the pass but I do think they have to
have powers which are strictly regulated
and we need the safeguards you know I
wasn't like any other and I don't want
to see any any scope for abuse I do on
the other hand want to see them actually
have regulated powers of a kind that
actually will keep us safe so I'm I'm I
mean I think that the the argument that
you actually should be entitled to
privacy absolutely and if the government
really gave
spend its time interfering with you know
communications of the kind which have
absolutely no link to national you know
what's out we don't have an absolute
right to privacy I think now you don't
have an absolute right to plot to kill
everybody in the world I mean this is
just a nonsense cyber cyber space
cyberspace is just the same as ordinary
space it needs policing and as we do
more and more of activity on there the
same rules need to apply in cyberspace
as play in what we currently call I
don't know
the police need powers under exceptions
and all the the Cabot's we've said all
the restrictions the ability to get in
there and police it because if it's not
policed then you've got an exception
you're treating cyberspace as if as if
fundamentally the rules of life are
different to ordinary life and I don't
think they're okay